Éste es el mismo problema del video anterior,
solo que ahorita quiero mostrarte otra forma
de resolverlo para ver que estos problemas
de proporciones se pueden hacer de más de una forma,
y que todas estas nos dan la respuesta
correcta, claro, si hacemos todo bien.
Voy a volver a leer el problema, dice,
una pipa puede llenar una alberca 1.5
veces más rápido que una segunda pipa.
Si ambas pipas están abiertas,
se llena en 6 horas.
Si solo la pipa lenta está abierta,
¿cuánto tiempo se tardará en llenar la alberca?
Bueno, como te comentaba es muy útil pensar
en razones de llenado, así que déjame llamarle
de alguna forma a la razón de llenado de
la pipa lenta...
lenta, vale.
Entonces vamos a pensar que la pipa lenta
llena "r", ésta va a ser la razón de llenado,
"r" albercas...
albercas...
por hora...
Entonces con esta información podemos determinar
la razón de llenado de la pipa rápida...
la pipa rápida, porque el problema nos dice
que la pipa rápida es 1.5 veces más rápida,
así es que su razón de llenado sería "1.5r"
albercas por hora...
albercas...
Muy bien y juntando esta información,
podemos obtener la razón combinada de llenado...
que voy a poner por acá en otro color...
la combinada y para esto simplemente tenemos
que sumar ambas razones,
la de la pipa lenta y de la rápida,
así que nos quedaría que la razón combinada
es "r" más "1.5r" albercas por hora...
albercas...
albercas por hora...
Muy bien, esto lo podemos simplificar un poco
como "2.5r" albercas por hora,
simplemente sumé, albercas...
albercas por hora...
y ahora vamos a ver que otra información
nos da el problema, nos dice que si ambas
están abiertas, entonces se llena una alberca,
de esta forma esta razón de llenado es igual a la razón de llenado que nos dan acá arriba,
es decir, a una alberca...
alberca...
1 alberca cada 6 horas...
horas...
Muy bien, ahora podemos igualar "2.5r" a 1/6
porque aquí tenemos las mismas unidades
y de esta forma obtenemos que "2.5r"...
"2.5r"...
la razón de llenado de la pipa lenta...
la pipa lenta...
es igual a 1/6.
Y aquí dividiendo entre 2.5 de ambos lados,
acá y acá, 2.5 obtenemos que "r"
es igual a 1 entre 6 por 2.5 y 6 por 2.5 es 15,
entonces "r" es igual a 1 entre 15
y por lo tanto la razón de llenado
de la pipa lenta es 1 entre 15,
la voy a poner aquí arriba,
¿esto qué nos dice?
Nos dice que se llena,
1/15 de alberca por hora
y de esta forma tardaríamos
15 horas en llenar 1 alberca.
Vamos a ver si eso responde la pregunta,
nos preguntan,
¿cuánto tiempo se tardará en llenar la
alberca si solo la pipa lenta está abierta?
Ah pues si eso es justo lo que hicimos,
entonces se tardaría 15 horas...
15 horas...
Muy bien, entonces es exactamente el mismo
problema del video anterior,
solo que aquí está resulto de otra forma,
que creo que es un poco más sencilla
pero a lo mejor no vale la pena...
ehhh... no vale la pena hacer la comparación
porque en el otro video expliqué más cosas.
Bueno, espero que te haya gustado,
nos vemos hasta la próxima.